- Hey friends of Evan Carmichael and Evan,
my friend, buddy, appreciate
you doing this takeaway on me.
An obsessed person doesn't
care if they don't like
that activity but they have to do it.
You're obsessed, you're
in it, you do it anyway,
no matter what.
Look, if you want to be in
business for yourself and free,
you must learn to dominate.
You cannot compete.
You should not get your advice from people
in the middle class about finances.
- Hello Believe Nation,
I'm Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe and
I believe that entrepreneurs
are going to solve all of the
major problems of the world.
So, to help you on your journey today,
we're going to learn from
motivational speaker, trainer,
and author, Grant Cardone,
and my take on his top
ten rules for success, volume two.
Rule number four is my personal favorite,
and I love to know which
one you guys like the best.
And as always, guys, as you're watching,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it down
in the comments below,
put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired,
and when you write it down,
it's much more likely to stick
for yourself as well, enjoy.
(deep drumming music)
(inspiring strong music)
- I hear a lot of guys
saying right now like,
hey, only do the things you want to do.
Dude, I do stuff I don't
want to do every single day.
(man laughing)
So, I don't know who these
people are that don't
do the things they don't want to do,
maybe they were given a
business or something.
But, I'm going to tell you something, man,
if you don't do the things
you don't want to do,
you're not going to grow your business,
you won't keep your business.
I'm telling you, you
have to be willing to...
You got to be so obsessed
that you don't care.
- Yeah.
- See, an obsessed person
doesn't care if they
have to clean a toilet.
- Uh huh, yup.
- An obsessed person doesn't
care if they don't like
that activity but they have to do it.
You're obsessed, you're
in it, you do it anyway,
no matter what.
I remember my mom told
me one day, she's like,
"You know, Grant, I love
you just the way you are."
Because I'm telling her
about all these dreams I have
as a child, right.
- Yeah.
- And I was reminded when
my sister told me like
30 years later, "You know,
Grant, you've done a lot.
"We love you just the way you are."
And I'm like, dude, I
wonder how many times
I've been told that.
- Wow.
- And the fact is, so what
they love me just the way I am.
I don't, I don't love
me just the way I am,
which opens up to this
whole field of people
that's like, just love
yourself the way you are.
Look, if you're broke, if
you're not living on purpose,
you don't like your job, you
can't get away from your job,
if you're stuck in a house you don't like,
why would you want to love that?
- Mmm.
- You should become obsessed
with hating it, man.
It's obsessed or average, one of the two.
So, pick, just pick!
Get a t-shirt, obsessed, or
get another t-shirt, average.
- Which one would you be
more proud wearing, right?
- Yeah, who do I want to be, man?
Who do I want to be?
How do I want to die, man?
I want to die all in.
Here's the deal, a guy
just hit me on Snapchat
and said, "Hey, man,
I'm going for it because
"I've only got one life to live."
And I snapped him back and just said,
"Hey, man, what if that one
life thing isn't true, bro?"
And now he's wondering, he's like,
"What you mean, man, what you mean?"
I said, "Well, here's the deal, okay.
"I mean, you don't know
and I don't know, right?
"I mean, maybe you
don't know, maybe I do."
But here's the deal,
I'm much more dangerous
and much more of a risk
taker, and much more a go
all the way dude, and
less introverted when
I'm not worried about the one life myth.
I'm thinking, hey, baby,
what if I live forever, man?
Then in my willing to take the risk?
Am I willing to make the sales call?
See, me living forever,
the immortality concept,
makes me way dangerous.
Makes me sick dangerous,
makes me crazy dangerous.
It makes me want to go for
it every freaking single day
because I don't have the ultimate to lose.
You understand what I'm saying?
Hey, check it out, maybe you
know, maybe you don't know,
but I'll bet you're curious.
What if you live forever?
What if this is like the thousandth time?
What if you got a 1,000
more runs in this deal?
Well then go for it!
Bottom line is one life or many lives,
go for it today, go for it in a big way,
and go for it like you're
going to live forever.
Look, if you want to be in
business for yourself and free,
you must learn to dominate.
You cannot compete.
How many were trained this,
competition is a healthy thing?
That message was not being
delivered to entrepreneurs.
That message was being
delivered to consumers.
There was somebody saying,
"Look, the more oil companies
"we have, the better because
it's good for the customer."
The more technology companies we have,
it's not just Microsoft,
the better for the customer.
And it envisions, and
improvements and products comes
from competition, but if you're
the one playing the game,
you want to dominate the field.
So, look, here's the
deal, I might be wrong in
what I say, I might be wrong
in the things I do in my life
and the business that I started.
My family's told me not
to start every business
that I've been involved
in, everyone of them.
Everyone of them was a risk,
everyone of them I had to take a chance.
I remember my mom used to tell me,
"I wouldn't do that if I were you.
"I wouldn't do that if I were you."
I'm like, "Mom, you wouldn't do anything."
(audience laughing)
You wouldn't do anything
except be the mother,
a great mother, to five children.
My mother wasn't an entrepreneur,
she didn't have my dreams.
Just because she's my mom
doesn't mean she dreams like me,
would you agree?
My mom was wrong about
everything she told me not to do.
Love my mom to death,
unbelievable friend of mine,
she was wrong.
I needed to do those things.
Steve Jobs needed to build
this phone, would you agree?
Did he help a lot of people?
Did he make some money
while he was doing it?
119 billion dollars in five
years, in the bank, cash.
I'm not talking about...
I'm talking about in the
bank, during, in the bank,
sitting there.
Brings a great product to the market,
price, domination or competition?
Total domination.
Coca-Cola, competition or domination?
Total domination, okay.
Exxon, total domination.
You see what I'm saying?
You want to be a dominating point.
So, what we've got to do is
we've got to get you thinking,
we've got to get you thinking
like the dominators think.
How do they act?
How does Warren Buffett act?
What does Warren Buffett do
with his time all the time?
Those are the people I study today.
I don't study the people
that I went to school with,
the teachers I went to school with,
I don't even study my own family members.
I'm looking for people
that are way up here
that I can say, "Hey, what are they doing?
"because they're doing it right."
I know that one of the key
things, one of the things
that's made me successful in my life
is making a priority
to control my thoughts.
What am I thinking about?
Like, literally putting discipline in on
how I talk to myself.
And, so I don't want this to
sound all psycho babble stuff,
it's not like, oh, if you
just stand in the mirror
and talk to yourself
and say positive things,
everything's going to be
all right, that's not true.
Be careful what you say to yourself.
Because if you're saying a
$30 steak is a lot of money,
or a $4 toy is a lot of money,
when your kid wants a $4 toy,
listen to what you're saying.
That's a lot of money.
$4 is a lot of money, on my worst day,
$4 has not been a lot of
money even though, okay,
I've been at periods of my
life where I didn't have $4.
So, I'm talking to you today
about how do you control,
how do you control, how do you discipline,
how do you start monitoring
what you're saying to yourself?
I can't find the right girl,
I can't find the right guy,
there's no good guys left in this town,
all men are pigs, women
cheat on their men,
marriage is hard, having
kids is difficult,
I don't want to pay taxes, I
can't help myself, I can't stop,
I can't trust myself,
I never do what I say,
I procrastinate, I'm an
introvert, I'm broke, I'm poor.
So, look, what are you saying
to yourself all the time?
The first thing I did was
I took a little journal out
and I just wrote down all the negative
things I say to myself.
By the way, I just gave you a list, okay.
I can't spend money, I
can't save enough money,
I don't make enough money,
I don't now how to invest
in the stock market, I
can't invest in real estate,
I don't have time to do this.
You know the time thing, people just kill
themselves with the time thing.
I don't have enough time,
I don't have enough time.
Guess what?
Oops, you don't have enough time.
You don't have time, you don't have money.
Catch yourself every time
you say I don't have time,
say hey, I create time.
Every time you say I don't
have money, I create money.
Or maybe just start literally
like talking to yourself,
that hey, I am a millionaire,
I am a multimillionaire.
If you're in the apartment game and
you want to be in apartments
but you don't know anything
about apartments, you can
start literally talking to
yourself saying, I am
worth, I own 100 units.
I did this for years, for years,
before I ever bought an
apartment, I used to write down,
"I own 20 apartments,
it owns 12% cash flow."
Over and over, I bet I
wrote this down 1,000 times.
I own 20 apartments, my
first deal was 38 units.
I own 20 apartments or more.
And I write it in any little journal,
any piece of paper, any legal pad.
Every time you say something
negative right now,
I need to lose weight.
Okay, that's good, but
if you're running a race,
you don't say I need to finish the race.
You're looking for the...
You got to run, right?
You got to run, you got
to move, you got to keep
moving your feet, so you
can sit there and say,
"I got to finish this
race," but the truth is,
if you need to lose weight, man,
just once you pick your target weight and
start affirming that I weigh 165 pounds,
I weigh 165 pounds, so just
switch it a little bit.
All you're trying to do is discipline,
you're trying to move the river.
So, if you're broke right
now, quit saying I am broke
and start saying what you want.
Where are you going?
You got to get some haters.
You need haters.
No school is going to teach
you how to get a hater.
High school, elementary school, colleges,
what do they teach?
You want to be the most popular person.
No, you want haters.
The companies that are hated are
the companies that are exploding.
The people that are hated
are the people that explode.
If I don't hate you, if nobody
hates you, nobody knows you.
So, the reason I'll Tweet, for
instance, when we started...
We had that newsletter
that I sent out, okay,
we send it out every week.
We were hitting people once a month
and we started getting complaints.
You send stuff out too much.
My office came to me, we
went to twice a month.
They came to me, we
have more people pulling
off of the newsletter.
Good, double up again.
Why, I want haters.
So, we started sending out one every week,
and then I start a Twitter account.
I actually had people
write, "Grant Cardone,"
social media people, "Grant
Cardone is an example
"of what not to do with social media."
I said, freaking, just multiply.
(audience laughing)
Just increase it, we were
doing like four Tweets a day.
Good, do two an hour.
Why, because I want my
competition hating my guts,
I want them talking about me.
I mean, I don't really
want people to hate me,
you understand what I'm saying about.
I want them so energized that they
actually start pushing me,
they start promoting me.
I use everyone of the news channels.
You'll see me on TV
doing news one day, okay.
I don't watch news, I make news.
See the shift, you see the slight shift?
Don't watch the news.
Decide when you leave here
today to make the news.
You don't read the newspaper,
you write newspaper articles.
You don't read books.
Yeah, read them, but learn to write them.
You don't need to spend a
lifetime writing a book,
this was three hours.
Okay, we sold 40,000
copies of this one book
and it was self published.
It's never, ever, ever
been in a bookstore.
A guy writes me, says, "Hey,
you got misspelled words
"all in that book."
(audience laughing)
I'm like, "Yeah, so what, where are they?"
"123, 128, 134, 165."
I'm like, "Yeah, yeah."
And bad grammar, too.
I'm like, "Yeah, what's your point, dude?
"What's your point, man, why
do you keep telling me that?"
He's like, "Because man,
"you got misspelled words in the book."
It's a bestseller (beep).
(audience laughing and applauding)
Okay, so what, it ain't
best written, okay.
(audio cuts out)
I don't want you to think
that that's a cuss word.
The word (beep), look
it up in the dictionary,
it means a complainer, or
whiner, and excuse maker.
I wear a little band on my
pin here, on my wrist here,
it's a little black band and
it says, "Champions dominate."
And on the other side,
"Don't be a little (beep)."
(audience laughing)
That's right.
Because I don't need it, I
need to get rid of the whiners,
the excuse makers.
Oh, my god, it's the market.
It's the market, oh my
god, prices, inventory!
Nine months ago, there's
too much inventory,
now too little inventory.
Dude, human beings have so many
excuses, it's unbelievable.
You know why?
Because you watch the news too much.
Because you've agreed to
receive news, not make news.
- My journalism professor
said the money will come,
follow your heart, follow your
passion, the money will come.
That's what was told to me.
- And he knew nothing about money,
otherwise he wouldn't
have been in his job.
- [Woman] You mean as a professor?
- He should not have been
giving you advice on money.
He doesn't have any
money, you've got people--
- But if his measurement
of success is not money
and it's prestige or--
- Then why's he giving
you advice on money?
That's my point.
My dad, my dad died when he was 52.
He made it in the middle class.
My mom and my dad thought they had made it
when the truth is the next week,
my mom had to sell the house
he bought so we could live.
That is not making it, okay.
You should not get your
advice from people in
the middle class about finances.
They don't know anything about finances.
If you know what day it is,
you are not busy enough.
I recently heard, this
week, oh, it's Monday,
man, it's so hard to
get started on a Monday.
I'm like, "How do you
even know it's Monday?"
I don't know what day it is.
On Wednesday, we hear it's hump back day,
we're halfway there.
So, it's Friday and it's like,
oh, thank god it's Friday,
or follow Friday, or like,
dude, how do you people
know what day it is?
You're not busy enough, you
need to be so freaking busy
that you don't know what time it is,
you don't know if it's
before lunch, after lunch,
before dinner, after dinner.
Come on, you've had those productive days.
Remember the day when
you were so productive,
you literally worked
through lunch and dinner
and you looked up at 7:00,
you should've been home an hour ago.
And you're like, dude, I
hadn't had lunch or dinner.
You know why?
Because that day, you were
eating the marketplace,
you were consuming the marketplace because
you were active, productive,
hitting it, slamming,
creative, and completely committed.
Look, that's where you need to be today.
Look, I don't know what
Monday, Wednesday, or Friday,
or I don't know about
Saturdays and Sundays.
I know this, create tremendous
amounts of activity,
so much activity that
you lose track of time.
Your success is not going
to come from watching TV
or looking at a calendar,
your success is going to come
from activity, from being
busy, from being obsessed,
from being so into it
that you don't know about,
oh my gosh, it's the Monday morning blues,
or Wednesday humpback, or Friday what?
(loud drumming)
Friday what, whatever!
Okay, get busy.
At different places in
life, I promise you,
you're going to find you
don't know where to go.
Everybody goes through this.
The most successful people
in the world wake up some
mornings with no clue what to do today.
So, first thing I want you
to know is that it's normal,
it happens to everybody, it's
not like you're a bad person
or you're lost, or you're depressed.
You got some problem you
need to take medication for.
Everybody, everybody, regardless
of their stature in life,
where they are, regardless of their money,
their relationship, their
job, they run the joint,
promise you, no matter
how much they present,
like they look like they got
the whole package put together,
everybody, everybody has those days.
Man, the sun is kicking today.
Has those days where they
don't know what to do.
They don't know what to
do, you know, uncertainty.
My friend Dale Christensen told
me when I was 25 years old,
I was experiencing depression everyday.
He's like, "No matter
what, man, no matter what,
"no matter what, dude, show up.
"Even if your eyes are bleeding, show up."
I've been doing that for 34 years now,
show up even when I don't want to.
And then what I try to do
is I try to help one person,
one person.
And what happened over
the period of 34 years,
I did that everyday, I'm
not depressed anymore,
at least not for long periods of a time.
I don't use any kind of medication,
don't use any kind of
drugs, don't smoke weed,
don't drink, excessively drink,
I might have a drink once in a while.
And got a beautiful
wife, two beautiful kids,
and for the most part, my
wife is freaking wonderful.
All I did was this, I don't over analyze,
never do I label myself
a loser, a quitter.
I'm hard on myself, I never
label myself OCD, ACD, ADD,
OCDD, whatever a depressant,
alcoholic, drug addict.
No, no I don't.
This is what I do, I do things, I show up,
move in the direction,
I don't overanalyze,
move in the direction
that I think could be more
pro survival than staying in one place.
And number three, help somebody.
Hey, friends of Evan
Carmichael and Evan, my friend.
Buddy, appreciate you
doing this takeaway on me.
I really, really appreciate
everything you've done for me,
and what you've done for
so many entrepreneurs.
I'm in Malibu right now, Evan.
I wish you'd get away from
New York this weekend,
come down and see me.
It's supposed to be June gloom brother.
But instead of June gloom,
it's June beautiful.
I'm hanging out in Malibu,
I've got my staff down here.
Hope you guys enjoyed the ten
takeaways that Evan liked,
I loved what he picked, hope you do, too.
If you have any questions
or comments for me,
please hit us up.
Evan, again, thanks for what you're doing,
appreciate you, man.
God bless and be great.
And believe.
(deep drumming)
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed.
If you want to get your pick
of who I should profile next
in the top tens, check out
the link in the description
and go and cast your vote.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Monika Tep.
Monika, thank you so much for
picking up copy of my book,
Your One Word, and taking
our picture with all
your other books.
It's an honor to be with
those great books as well.
So, thank you so much for the support,
and I'm glad you enjoyed the read.
So, thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you, I hope you
continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
(deep dramatic music)
- First thing you got to
get right if you want to
be in the sales game
today is you got to get
your freaking financial literacy right.
You got to get your mind,
money, financial mindset right.
You got to start thinking
about taking your finances
from the level you are
to the level where you
and your family deserve to be.
Now, you know this is true.
People that are not making enough money
simply make sense of why
they're not making enough money.
Money's not going to make me
happy, I'm fine where I am,
I'm doing better than people
that live in Afghanistan.
Well, none of that makes sense if you have
the potential to make more money.
If you have a great
product, a great company,
and you know another
call, another strategy,
one more little, maybe, angle,
something that you could persist with.
If you know that you
could be making more money
and you aren't, let's
get that fixed, okay.
I wrote this little book called
The Millionaire Booklet, this
took about two hours to write.
This took me 30 years to put together.
This is the playbook to millions.
We actually called it Playbook
to Millions originally,
and Google and Facebook
wouldn't let me advertise it
because they said you
can't promise to make
people millionaires, I said,
"No, you can't, I can."
I've made millionaires.
And the first thing to
becoming a millionaire,
a multimillionaire, a
hecta-millionaire or a billionaire,
and I spend time with
enough billionaires now,
is they have made decisions
to get their money right.
Whether they're going
public or selling a product,
scaling out, they had to make
a decision to get the money,
the finance model of their
household, their business,
their product, or their IPO right.
Right, if they want to go to the market
and become a public company.
So, number one, get your money right.
It's not about product knowledge first,
it's not about sales knowledge first,
it's not about sales process first,
it's not about the follow up first
or writing the customer up first.
It's not even about attitude first,
it's about get your financial, mental,
get your (mumbles) mental right, okay?
Because if you're satisfied,
if you're happy where
you are financially, why
would you sell anything else?
Look, let's face it, you want commission,
you get paid to sell things,
you get paid to close deals,
you get paid to follow
up only when it works.
Number one, get your money mindset right.
This is your target right here.
You know, this is how big,
that's what you should be going after.
Because this guy, this point over here,
might actually (mumbles).
I want people in South Korea
and North Korea to know me,
I don't care if they're communists.
Doesn't matter to me, dude.
Kim Jong Won Kong, whatever, I don't care.
I want all these particles.
These are particles,
these are people, right.
I want them all to know my name.
Because if they all know my name, dude,
they send a vibration
to that guy, I got it.
People don't know you,
they don't buy from you.
There's an old saying,
people got to like you to buy from you.
It's not true, people
have to know you, though.
IF they don't know you,
they won't trust you.
The more they hear your name,
the more this one point
right here, this name,
oh, I think I can trust that name.
When I grew up, I thought
I needed to market here.
This was my market.
It was a mistake, man, my
market should've been out here.
That means you need money, though,
because a lot of this marketing
is going to be wasted.
You know?
And it takes a lot of energy,
man, so you need your team...
For me to market to this
one guy is one energy level.
For me to market to all
these people everyday,
you got to remember, these
people are in a different
timezone than these people.
So, I get eight hours of sleep,
the other 16 hours a
day, it's hammer down,
maybe with a 10 minute nap.
It's freaking hammer down,
that means I need my wife
and my kids all with me,
onboard, all the time,
16 hours I need to hit.
And early on, I didn't
have that because I didn't
have the girlfriends.
You know, he knows to
come in with the camera,
those guys over there know to light up,
you got to get your team right
because that's what you're taking on.
You're not taking on this guy.
See, this is where everybody
goes into business,
thinking I'm going to
get my business plan.
But look, the business plan
is this, it's on this, right?
This is what your business plan is.
You need energy to go to these places.
So, I don't need a girlfriend saying,
"Could we just cuddle?"
(people laughing)
Dude, I ain't got time to cuddle,
I'm trying to do this thing, okay.
Why don't you help me do this thing
and then we got some time to cuddle?
So, really, really important to get
everybody on the same page.
Had an idea, took it to the marketplace,
learned how to pitch it,
changed my environment,
started hanging around winners.
Where are the winners?
They're on top of the hill, bro.
They ain't at the bottom of the hill.
They're not at the Holiday
Inn and the Marriott,
they're not where my mama told me to go.
My mama told me to save
everything, save everything,
save everything, and she
taught me that for one reason,
because she didn't know how to make money.
See, what I've done,
look I'm 58 years old,
just turned 59, actually.
I'm going to spend the rest
of my life helping people,
figure out what I did.
Everybody should have...
Everybody should be able to do this,
everybody should have the opportunity
to take their family,
their kids, their wife,
their husband, take them wherever
they want to go, everybody.
The truth is everybody
does have the opportunity.
Most people just are not
willing to read, study, learn.
So now, if you are one of those people,
here's a little warning to you,
you got to pick your mentors carefully.
I talk to Captain Ryan all the time.
I'm like, "Captain Ryan, you
just can't listen to everybody,
"dude, you can't study everybody."
Those of you out there
that are studying you like
you're opening up every
Facebook feed, every Snapchat,
looking at every YouTube video.
You have to pick, pick,
you got to pick, see, these
are good people, right?
You got to pick who you're
going to learn from.
You have to be selective.
If I'm somebody who you resonate with,
study me, okay.
If I'm not, if I'm not the guy,
then find somebody that's made it.
Not just money, but has
time for their family,
time for vacations, time for spirituality,
time to take care of
their physical condition,
time to give back, time for charity,
time to help the military out.
Those guys are out there
serving over there.
Look, find somebody
that matches your values
and study that person deep.
(deep drumming)